No wonder people disliked this research.
It's so,
it's so anti egalitarianism and it's
essential and it's essential structure.
Well,
I wanted to make a second point that I
said would be provocative if you want to
do something about this and you know,
be tried to a bunch of interventions,
earnest,
well funded,
warm term interventions
don't seem to work,
but no science has been excluded from
discussions about what to do about this
and I believe that neuroscience,
the progress in neuroscience research
has the potential to really dramatically
increase the g factor.
Well that's an optimistic statement,
so I'm sure looking forward
to some support for that one.
It's optimistic and reversal and you know,
just as a thought experiment,
and I can tell you why I
believe this is possible.
What will first,
before I tell you the thought experiment,
the reason I,
I'm optimistic is that B is because of
the high heritability of the g factor.
That means your genes are involved.
Gene's work through biology,
even if environment interacts with that,
but basically you have a
neuro biological system.
It's complex,
but as you begin to understand it,
you can tweak it.
This is what all medicine is doing now.
They're trying to understand the neural
biology slash genetic basis of our
health and our diseases.
Why?
So they can fix it.
So they didn't get,
when you go to the doctor,
you're going to cause your biology is
broken and you let your biology fixed.
Well,
let's think about the brain.
Now,
no one conceptualize as low Iq is a
disease and it's a little dangerous.
But to the extent to which low Iq has
a genetic input or a genetic influence,
that's the extent to which you might
be able to to find out how that works,
how that's what that system is,
and then figure out how to tweak
that system to increase Iq.
It's not science fiction.
I mean that's it.
That's a plausible sequence of events.
What the problem is,
it's a very complex sequence,
the shirt,
but I also think it's a
finite set of problems,
not an infinite set of problems.
So no physicists,
physicists configure out what happened
during the first nanoseconds of the big
bang.
We can certainly figure out what the
neurobiology of intellect it is and how to
tweak it.
So I think that's possible.